[Music]
hello
we often get questions from companies
about how to document and transfer their
api programs knowledge
across distributed teams enter the api
playbook
the api playbook is a living document
that guides the overall direction
of your api program when we consider the
digital value chain
every aspect is an integral part of the
api playbook
for example how to ensure your apis are
secure
what processes will you have in place to
connect your backend services
to your applications and how will you
engage your community and customers
to ensure your api program is successful
these questions
and others all need to be answered the
playbook describes your approach to api
management as a whole
it includes the essential standards that
all apis must follow for an organization
the best practices for designing apis in
a common
and consumer-friendly fashion and the
essential ways of working
for api producing teams to produce
quality apis
at speed and scale your playbook should
focus
on six key areas your organization
best practices api design decisions
development requirements api management
and deployment processes
and overall support guidelines this
should be a living document
derived from industry best practices and
best of all
experience of people inside your company
here's a condensed summary of various
items that will appear
in a playbook every business is unique
and as a result every api playbook is
also unique
to that business let's take a closer
look
at the core topics and what information
you may find
in each section in this section apis in
your organization
explains how api governance ownership
and federation works
it's important to stress who and how
apis will manage
as well as what types of apis are in
your organization
as well as what api teams and roles
should be
and what they do your guideline and
guiding principle to follow here is as
you move towards a comprehensive api
program
you should have an api first mandate
from leadership
direct your digital product owners and
api teams
to own their apis and leverage a common
infrastructure
with common design patterns that flow
throughout the entire organization
successful apis require more than good
technology
you will need to ensure your team is
equipped with the right people
and processes traditional development
processes
or waterfall project management simply
doesn't work when a team has to respond
to opportunities feedback or problems
quickly this section covers best
practices
for organization using agile development
for apis
outline your software development life
cycle how your teams will maintain
quality assurance and what strategies
you'll focus on for mocking your data
and how all these ways of working might
be automated
your guiding principle here is simple
successful teams are agile
nimble and leverage automation
at a large enterprise many different
lines of businesses and
api teams will be producing apis and
it's a slippery slope of
discordant design if we don't all follow
the similar guidelines
this section details the important
aspects of your api design
and helps to guide a consistent look and
feel and function
of all the apis in your catalog you get
your guiding principle
your api should be designed as products
with an outside in view
allowing developers and consumers to
easily read
and understand your data in the
development section of your api playbook
document how you will facilitate
security as well as other patterns and
policies
which are required in the enterprise
provide guidance
on how user authentication will be
managed as well as
any other policies for logging
transformation or
orchestration these are often mandatory
development guidelines
regardless of what the functionality the
api exposes
your guiding principle here is to
provide reusable
shared flows assets and other patterns
designed to help your api teams go to
market faster
in this section we detail the
configurations necessary
for a successful pathway to production
it should outline each step of your
continuous integration
and delivery process and the tools used
furthermore it should list each
environment and what that environment is
used for
you can also include lists of analytics
reports that will help support auditing
governance
marketing and ongoing development
you should also include steps to prepare
technical and non-technical
documentation
for the developer portal your guiding
principle here is the
your software development lifecycle
should be tightly coupled
with continuous integration and delivery
tools
that manage your apis from coding to
deployment to monitoring
and analysis in your support section
explain how your developer portal will
be used and managed
discuss how you will support your
community with documentation around faqs
troubleshooting support steps and
resources you might make available to
them
investing the time to create a good
resource and support workflows
will pay dividends when it comes to both
your customers and your own
organization's time
your guiding principal your consumers
and customers are your customers
and a good customer experience is a
critical factor for building useful apis
a thriving community will ultimately
help your api program
to grow and become successful hopefully
you now have
a solid outline to build your first api
playbook
if you want more information please
check out the community for ebooks
articles and other related topics thank
you for watching